It's great to welcome to the program today,
Dean Baker, who's a senior economist at the
Center for Economic and Policy Research, also
a visiting professor at the University of
Utah. Uh, so great to talk to you, dean.
It's good to be on. Thanks for having me.
So to start with, there's so many areas I'm
curious, uh, about your take on that are relevant
to sort of recent political economic discussions.
We could talk about automation. There's the
debt and deficit football that is often in
the news. There is the discussion of where
are we heading towards a recession and how
would we know when we are in it, but maybe
to figure out what you think might be most
most productive. Is there a particular area
where you believe that the sort of corporate
mainstream discussion and framing of an economic
topic is just way off where we need to like
completely realign even how we're thinking
of the parameters of the debate?
Yeah, there actually is. It's an area that
I worked on kind of as a spare time thing
for really decades and the, this is pattern
in copyrights and that's kind of sounds obscure
to people and that's a big problem because
pants and copyrights are hugely, hugely important
in the economy. And just to put it as simply
as possible. There's a very commonly held
view, certainly among economists and people
in policy discussions that technology is responsible
or at least partly responsible for upward
redistribution of income. So the idea is that
you have these people in stem, people do computer
work or you could point to a bill gates, you
know, they get really rich and it just because
the technology and then you have, you know,
the people who have less education will say,
people use college degrees as a cutoff. It's
still about two thirds of the workforce who
don't have college degrees and they end up
just being losers.
So a classic story is someone working on the
assembly line, a UAW, uh, in an auto factory
that, that used to be a good paying job. You
could support a family on any of healthcare
insurance or pension. Well, those jobs just
aren't that valuable anymore. And the story
goes this, this is, you know, I might say
it's unfortunate it's technology. And the
point about patents and copyrights are those
are government policies. And those determine
who are the winners who get the benefits from
technology. And just to go back to our friend
Bill Gates, Bill Gates is incredibly rich
because he has copyrights patents also on
Microsoft software. The government will arrest
people who use Microsoft software without
his permission. Nope. Then that is a policy
we, it obviously serves a purpose. We have
patents, we have copyrights provide incentive
for innovation, incentive for creative work,
but that's a policy to do it and the point
is they could be stronger or they could be
weaker, they could be shorter, we can have
weaker penalties, stronger penalties for violating
them, and there are alternatives. We already
fund an awful lot of creative, innovative
work and most importantly national institutes
of health. We can fund more that way.
So Dean, let, Jay, I just want to make sure
I'm understanding what you're saying. There's
this idea when we talk about tech jobs, jobs
for people with or without college degrees,
the sort of potential of these different types
of jobs. And very often the sort of fate of
those decisions is maybe too much attributed
to the choices that the individual makes about
going or not going to college, the type of
field that they want to work in. But what
you're saying is that with regard to the technology,
the potential of technology jobs, that rather
than being a sort of virtue of the decisions
made by the individual, it's the framework
established around intellectual property by
the government that has kind of created this
environment to begin with.
Exactly. So the fact that there's a lot of
money in the tech sector, that's a policy
decision. And again, you could even say it's
a good policy decision, it's the, that's fine.
But the point was this didn't just happen.
So when we get all these people started going,
you know, we really feel bad for those people
are left behind. You Go, well they weren't
left behind. We pushed them behind.
I'm curious about. So, okay, here's an example
question that's often asked, uh, that we could
either answer as asked or we could point out
that the framing is the wrong framing. So
there's this question of the gap between CEO
pay and average worker pay at corporations.
If I ask my former University of Massachusetts
economics professor Richard Wolf about what
is the correct ratio between CEO pay and average
worker pay, he would say the entire system
is screwed. We need to be looking at democratizing
the workplace, the right, he would have a
systemic critique rather than one of just
saying, well, it should be limited to like
a hundred x or something like that. How does
someone like you approach a question like
that of CEO pay to average worker?
Okay, well I'm fine with the more systemic,
uh, critique, you know, I'd be fine with having
workers have more say in the way companies
are run and everything. Yeah. But I think
there's an important misconception about the
current system that, you know, I started saying
I, I guess my view is always, if you can't
take small steps, the idea you're somehow
going to take a big leap is at least to me,
fairly unlikely. So one of the points I've
made about CEO pay is it's coming at the expense
of shareholders. So there was a big deal made
about a month or so ago, the business round
table that includes all the major companies,
JP Morgan's in there and Bill Gates and Microsoft,
all the big companies are in there. They said,
oh, we should no longer be concerned with
just maximizing shareholder value. We have
to be concerned about our work or about the
environment, about the community.
What did you, okay, those are all good things.
But the point of aid was you were not just
concerned about maximizing shareholder value.
You are concerned about maximizing CEO pay.
She, your pay is going up 940% over the last
four decades. And you know, guess what returns
to shareholders over the last two decades
actually been very poor by historic standards
that you could argue what they should get.
I mean that's open question, but the point
is returns to shareholders in the last two
decades have actually been really weak by
historic standards. So if they've been maximizing
shareholder value, they do a really bad job
of it. So my point is that what's going on
with cos is that basically they're ripping
off their shareholders and that's because
of the structure of corporate governance.
The people determine their pay or their boards
of directors who are most immediately responsive
to the CEOs.
So again, I'd be happy to see workers have
more say in the way corporations are run.
But I would just settle for having shareholders
have more say in the way corporations are
run. Cause CEOs would get an awful lot less
money and that affects the distribution of
wages up and down the economy. Cause if the
CEO's getting 20 million, in many cases they
are person right underneath them. The chief
financial officer, the other top people, they're
probably getting 10 12 million. The third
tier is getting two or 3 million and back
where I learned my arithmetic. If those people
are getting more, everyone else must be getting
less cause that's taking a big chunk of the
corporate bond.
You said something at the beginning of of
this topic, which is if we can't take small
steps, it's not totally logical to think that
we could take the really big steps, and this
is a conversation I've had very often as someone
myself identifies as a social democrat with
those who, who designate themselves as socialists,
who want socialization of the means of production
and, and want to go way further than I want
to go. And I've pointed out, it seems to me
that in the immediate what you want is not
even a possibility and that what you want
is only going to happen if we first get to
what I want. So really we should be working
together rather than disagreeing what the
end point is. Is that a reasonably pragmatic
in your mind when it comes to a lot of these
economic questions or am I maybe missing some
other component here?
I think that's very, very much on the line
cause on the mark because the reality is we
could all think of, you know, sort of grand
visions that we would like to see the world,
uh, look like. But those are going to be really,
really hard to get to. And if all we're thinking
of as the grand vision, well odds are we're
not gonna make any progress. And, uh, you
know, people are living their lives and if
they go without health care, that's a really
big deal. So we could have our grand vision,
but they're not getting health care if we're
not doing anything to address climate change.
You know, again, we could ever agree on vision
of what the world should look like, but you
know, for obsessed with them, we're not thinking,
okay, what can we do tomorrow? What can we
do that it's gonna have an impact. Now, ideally
you have a longer term strategy, so you aren't
just doing things randomly like, oh, this
is a good thing to do tomorrow and then, well
something else to do the next day. You do
have some framework in which these these steps
make sense, but to just say, oh, I have my
grand vision, end of story. Well then you're
going to be talking about your grand vision
and basically doing nothing,
I guess to defend the view of those who have
a more, you might have to tear it down to
build it back up the right way mentality.
They would maybe argue that when you look
at some of the major economic issues, uh,
including for example, inequality, the disproportionate
power of corporations over our daily lives
in endless different way. When you, when you
ask what are the really big issues here, it's
not crazy to think that unless you really
do away with the power structures that got
us to where, where we are, we will never have
the bigger change. And maybe that's how someone
would defend focusing on the grand vision
rather than what we can do right now.
Well I have to say that one really doesn't
make a lot of sense to me because the idea
is stuff, how we're going to have it all come
crashing down. I mean, that's, that's, uh,
I'm sorry. I just think that's crazy wishful
thinking and you know, at the end of the day,
that means we're not doing anything that we're
not addressing really important issues, you
know, so, um, we're going to hope it keeps
coming. Cra, it'll come crashing down. In
the meantime, we're gonna destroy the planet
with, you know, throwing out so much greenhouse
gas emissions that, you know, it's a, I'm
not going to say it's never a reversible,
but it will devastate, you know, life as we
know it. I, I, that doesn't make sense to
me
when it comes to the discussions of recession.
Um, what, what is your barometer for determining
if an economy is in a recession? Is it that
important to make that determination? Um,
uh, in, in any kind of definitive way. If
qualitatively you can identify things that
are going well and things that are not going
so well. What, what's your general sense of
the, the way that discussion has been carried
out?
Well, the conventional view of a recession,
two quarters of negative growth, that's not
two consecutive quarters of negative growth.
That's not rigorously defined. I mean in other
words, the 2001 recession, we actually didn't
have two quarters of negative growth. But
in any case, to my view, whether we're technically
in a recession or not, may at the end of the
day not be that important. Cause the big issues
are things like, well basically do people
have jobs or are people seeing rising real
wages? Um, did people feel they can quit their
job if they don't like it? Uh, cause there's
a strong labor market, they can quit their
job and get another job somewhere else. Those
are, those are word I think of as big things.
And right now they call me the labor market
looks reasonably good if it weekends, if we
start to see the unemployment rate go up a
lot and we start to see wages, uh, slow, um,
that's a big problem. Whether or not we're
in a recession. So whether we could technically
say, okay, negative growth, that's a recession.
Um, that won't matter if it turns out to be
the case that workers, uh, the unemployment
rates rising and workers lose their ability
to secure wage gains.
There's this indicator that I've looked a
little bit at, which is kind of a proxy indicator
to what may be coming, which is the percentage
of people who are 90 days or more behind on
car payments. The idea being that a one's
ability to stay current on car payments relates
to a lot of other elements of the economy
being able to get to work, which often depends
on that job and that there may be some reasonable
way in which it's a proxy indicator to what
may be upcoming, whether or not you want to
comment on that particular metric. Do you
believe that there are advance measures, advanced
metrics that are more relevant to figuring
out whether a recession is coming than others?
Or are is anybody who's telling you these
are the three things you want to look at simplifying?
Well, when I look back at the recessions posts
post World War Two, um, there are common features.
They're basically two stories with post World
War Two recessions. One is that we start to
see higher inflation. The Fed reserve raises
interest rates to counter that tries to slow
the economy and they go too far. So when they
raise rates that causes people to buy fewer
cars, buy fewer houses, they stop refinancing,
mortgages, all those things dampen growth.
And you know, if they go too far then it gives
you a recession. The other way you get recession
is when a bubble burst. And that's of course
what happened in 2008, 2009, where the housing
bubble burst and give us a very severe recession
fashion. That was also really the story of
the 2001 recession that we had the stock bubble
burst. And, uh, technically that's not considered
a serious recession.
I considered a bad one because if you look
at the labor market, we continue to lose jobs
and recession officially ends in December
of 2001. We continue to lose jobs all through
2002 in most of the way through 2003. And
we didn't get back the jobs we lost until
January of 2005. So to my view, that was a
serious recession. But long and short, when
we're looking for cues, you know, in advance
warning, the two stories, one, do we have
a bubble that's about to burst and for that,
you know, I don't, I don't see any bubbles
that are driving the economy and I did see
both the stock bubble and housing bubbles.
So you know, I do look for things like that.
I don't see anything there. Now the other
stories, the Fed raising interest rates aggressively,
well we never got the interest rate all that
high know Donald Trump was yelling about it.
But you know, the interest rate, the Fed's
interest rate never got about two and a half
percent, that just lowered it twice. I don't
see either story of a recession. So the classic,
um, causality for a recession, the Fed or
bursting bubble, it's just not there. So I,
I really don't see one on the horizon
looking forward. The topic of automation is
getting more and more attention when it comes
to the presidential race. Uh, it's been mostly,
uh, Andrew Yang who has been talking about
it and I've read some pieces saying that this
is an overblown fear that in the same way
that in the past technology has destroyed
some jobs and industries, but always created
more that that will continue to happen. On
the other hand, there are papers I've read
which say the rate at which that has happened
in the past is changing and over time technology
will destroy more jobs than the number it
creates possible to know that at this point
in time. What's your sense of the importance
of this automation issue?
Well, what I find ironic, and I just did a
little paper looking at productivity and the
share portion productivity growth that's going
to to workers and first point out is we've
actually, we're actually in a period of extraordinarily
weak productivity growth. So for all the talk
of automation, if you actually look at the
data, we're actually losing jobs to technology
at a historically low rate. You know, I know
all these people, I know a lot of people push
that argument, they go, we have all this great
technology and maybe it is great, but the
fact is it's not affecting the economy. So
the idea that we're about to lose all these
jobs to technology, I just see basically zero
basis for that. And if it did happen, I mean
if he were to see a more rapid rate of productivity
growth, that would be great. That would create
a possibility of more rapid wage growth. We
could work fewer hours. I just, I, this is
store a story with basically no reality whatsoever
to it. So it's not one of the things that
keeps me up at night.
What is the thing that keeps you up at night
when it comes to the economy?
Well, I'd have to say with the economy, uh,
I don't know whether you want to call it the
economy or not. I mean, global warming is
a huge, huge issue and you know, we're doing
nothing on it. I mean, I, you know, Donald
Trump seems to think it's a good thing to
put us, throw as much greenhouse gases into
the environment as possible. And unfortunately
the u s is still such a big actor in the world
that if we just ignore any efforts to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions, it makes it a really
big problem. And of course it makes, you know,
other countries, you know, obviously they're
looking to us and not, you know, you can say
as a leader. But the other point is, well,
if we're out there spewing as much greenhouse
gases as we can into the atmosphere, probably
doesn't make sense for, you know, a France
or Germany or UK to do anything cause it won't
matter.
Um, so that, that is, you know, to my view
far away the most pressing thing and I'm hugely
concerned about inequality. And you know,
what bothers me is we don't discuss the issue
the right way. I was going on about patents
and copyrights. I raised this with economist
and they looked at me blank faced. And it's
not that I think economists are brilliant
people, but this is their topic. And the idea
that we can't, you know, they, they'll give
me this story about, Oh, Robert income upward
redistribution may come. That's unfortunate,
but that's just technology. And then got,
well supposedly their patents and copyrights
and then look at me, well, if we didn't patents
and copyrights, we'd have no incentive. I
go, okay, fine. But then you just told me
that's a policy. So, you know, but anyhow,
there's a tendency just to treat it as, as
blob that like, oh, we have inequality. And
it's really unfortunate. Even people on the
left, I mean they want to have progressive
taxes, which I think are great, but they treat
the underlying cause of inequality as being
something that's intrinsic to the market as
opposed it was how we structured the market.
Yeah, and it's amazing how, I mean when you
talk about economics in variably climate change
comes up when you talk about national security
in variably climate change comes up and it
is a, it's an issue with the far far reaching
tentacles for sure. Um, we've been speaking
with economists, Dean Baker, who's a senior
economist at the Center for Economic and Policy
Research, also a visiting professor at the
University of Utah. Dean, I really
appreciate your time today. Thanks Lebron.
Yeah, and I really enjoyed the discussion